41 globos para 41 niñas a quienes se les
arrebató la vida en la ciudad de
Guatemala se conmemora el sexto
aniversario del incendio de un hogar
para menores a cargo del estado
ya empecé a llorar porque yo pensé que
estaba quemada al ver a las demás así
porque yo pienso que
que en otros países con una niña que si
hubiera quemado así y hubieran
reaccionado Y por qué nuestro gobierno
nuestro estado nuestra Guatemala No no
ha dado respuestas realmente Mayra aidé
chután Urías que exigimos
después de seis años el juicio aplazado
12 veces no ha empezado
ha habido toda clase de estrategias de
parte de la defensa por ejemplo no
asistir a las audiencias reportarse
enfermos que por una u otra razón que el
tráfico
los padres Aún se mantienen de pie
reclamando justicia heridas salguero
madre de Keyla una joven de 17 años que
perdió la vida en ese incendio aún no
asimila la pérdida de su hija como que
key la me los hubiera mandado a mí el
montón de rosas
para su mamá que no esté triste que ella
está conmigo siempre en el tiempo que
ocurrió el incendio las menores del
hogar seguro venían denunciando golpizas
abusos sexuales e incluso trata de
personas porque las niñas las abusaban
por eso es que ellos quieren que esto se
quede así no quieren que esto siga
verdad para que haya una justicia porque
saben que queremos llegar al punto de la
violencia que ellos estaban sufriendo
ahí adentro
varias familias de víctimas afirman ser
blanco de amenazas aún así han decidido
que no dejarán de alzar la voz para
conseguir justicia por la muerte de sus
hijas